weltweit entsetzen über die ereignisse
in den usa
anhänger des abgewählten präsidenten
trump stürmen gestern das kapital
liefern sich auseinandersetzungen mit
dem sicherheitspersonal
eine frau wird getötet die randalierer
dringen in büros ein und in den
geräumten senat sei ein angriff auf das
herz der us demokratie das aber schlägt
weiter nachdem alles unter kontrolle ist
besiegelt der kongress endgültig trumps
wahlniederlage
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster und damit guten abend und
willkommen an einem nachrichten tag der
es in sich hat aber auch sport gibt es
in einer guten viertelstunde mit norbert
lehmann einstellungen werden so von mir
dieser mittwoch hat sich jetzt schon ins
politische gedächtnis eingebrannt
als tiefpunkt was sich da in washington
abgespielt hat steht für eine
entwicklung die vor vier jahren mit
präsident trump ihren anfang nahm
ein fortwährender angriff auf
institution und tradition der us
demokratie mit seiner rede gestern hatte
trump den mob zu seinem gewalttätigen
aufstand aufgehetzt spät in der nacht
wurde dann doch noch formell
festgestellt wofür man eigentlich
zusammen gekommen war dass joe biden der
nächste präsident der usa wird und
amtsinhaber trump lässt mitteilen dass
es einen zitat geordneten übergang zu
beiden geben werde
das ende eines tages von dem aber wohl
diese bilder in erinnerung bleiben
werden trump anhänger die das kapitol in
washington erstürmen
anselm stern berichtet
gestern brechen die scheiben bricht der
sturm losbrechen die extremisten ein ins
herz der amerikanischen demokratie
glühende anhänger von donald trump
stürmen das capitol stoppen
vorübergehend die sitzung volksvertreter
mit gasmasken fliehen vor dem wütenden
mob der den demokratischen prozess
aufhalten will mit gewalt die zuständige
capital police überfordert machtlos muss
weichen
[Applaus]
es fallen auch schüsse eine frau wird
getroffen und stirbt wenig später
während im us parlament die anarchie
regiert angestachelt aufgewiegelt vom
amtierenden präsidenten der vereinigten
staaten vor der gewaltaktion seiner fans
hatte dort kramp eine rede gehalten in
washington
wir wollen nicht dass unser wahlsieg
gestohlen wird von den radikalen linken
das tun sie wir werden niemals aufgeben
lasst uns die pennsylvania avenue
herunterlaufen die straße zum kapitän
dieser aufforderung kamen viele nach
stunden lang dauerte die besetzung die
gewalt mit dabei auch neonazis auschwitz
arbeit macht frei steht auf seinem
pullover secret service agenten müssen
ihre waffen ziehen chaos in der
hauptstadt der mächtigsten nation der
welt
die worte eines präsidenten machen einen
unterschied egal wie gut oder wie
schlecht er ist die worte können im
besten fall inspirieren im schlechtesten
fall auf früheren die rede von joe biden
danach kam er noch einmal zurück
genug ist genug ruft er selbst
republikaner flehten aus dem kapital
heraus trump möge den mob zurückrufen
die botschaft die dann kommt klingt so
ich weiß wie ihr euch fühlt aber jetzt
müsst ihr friedlich nach hause gehen wir
lieben euch ihr seid etwas besonderes
die vom präsidenten so gelobten
hinterlassen verwüstung die polizei
übernimmt wieder die kontrolle nach
langen stunden nach der historischen
attacke auf amerikas demokratie in
washington hat elmar theveßen die
ereignisse für uns beobachtet zunächst
einmal die frage immer wie es überhaupt
so weit kommen konnte warum war die
polizei denn so gar nicht vorbereitet ja
da ist ein ganz großes fragezeichen die
capital police hat eigentlich über 2.000
beamte von denen sah man aber gestern
nur wenige dutzend keine ahnung ob
irgendwo noch eine bereitschaft
vorhanden war eigentlich wusste man
vorher genau was passieren könnte es war
eine demonstration mit über 30.000 trump
anhängern angekündigt ist war bekannt
dass milizen in der stadt seien würden
dass die stimmung aufgeheizt ist das
möglicherweise auch waffen mitgebracht
werden
trotzdem völlige unterbesetzung und
überforderung der capital pullis und
umso wichtiger ist vielleicht das eben
am abend dann der kongress doch die
geschäfte wieder aufgenommen hat
sicherlich erschüttert aber nicht
gebrochen wie unsere kollegin ines trams
brands berichtet soll präsident trump
aus dem amt entfernt werden nach dem
heutigen tag dieser reporter frage
weicht der vizepräsident aus also mit
abgeordneten und senatoren die sitzung
nach dem tumult wieder aufnehmen will
draußen hatte sich mit der
ausgangssperre die lage beruhigt
eskortiert von nationalgardisten zurück
in den sitzungssaal
erschüttert sind sie politiker beider
seiten verweisen auf trump dieser tag
hinterlässt ein schandfleck auf unserem
land der nicht leicht auszuradieren sein
wird es ist das endgültige schreckliche
vermächtnis des 45 präsidenten er war
ohne zweifel unser schlimmster wir haben
einen aufstand erlebt an
zettelt von dem präsidenten der
vereinigten staaten dennoch legten auch
nach dem sturm aufs kapital samt getreue
kongressmitglieder erneut einspruch
gegen das wahlergebnis ein
sie wurden niedergestimmt am frühen
morgen wurde joe biden formell als
sieger ausgerufen
joseph biden aus delaware hat 306
stimmen bekommen derweil sperrt twitter
trump für zwölf stunden facebook bis auf
weiteres so dass er seine lügen vom
wahlbetrug nicht mehr verbreiten kann
stattdessen lässt er nun seinen sprecher
twittern obwohl ich dem ausgang der wahl
überhaupt nicht zustimmen kann und die
fakten für mich sprechen wird es dennoch
am 20 januar eine ordentliche
amtsübergabe geben
gestern hatte trump seine anhänger noch
angefeuert auf das kapitol zu
marschieren erste rufe werden nun laut
ihn nach dem 25 verfassungszusatz des
amtes zu entheben rufe auch von
republikanern
der präsident hat sich losgesagt von
seinen pflichten und der realität
deswegen fordere ich den
vize-präsidenten und das kabinett auf
sicherzustellen dass die nächsten wochen
für das amerikanische volk sicher sind
13 tage noch bis zur amtsübergabe 13
ungewisse tage das capitol die us
demokratie sind verwundbarer als viele
glaubten ja und wie geht es nun mit tram
weiter könnte er tatsächlich kurz vor
toresschluss noch seines amtes enthoben
werden elmar also für ein formales sams
enthebung verfahren im kongress fehlt es
sicherlich an der zeit was theoretisch
möglich wäre die absetzung von trump
dafür bedarf es einer mehrheit im
kabinett und des vize präsidenten mike
pence um ihn gewissermaßen für
unzurechnungsfähig zu erklären
tatsächlich haben gestern einige berater
im weißen haus offenbar darüber
diskutiert weil sie aus ihrer sicht
anzeichen von wahnsinn beim präsidenten
erkannt haben wollen
ich glaube trotzdem nicht dass sie den
mut finden dieser absetzung
durchzuziehen
und wenn diese anzeichen zu sehen waren
dann wird das natürlich die frage auf
was in den nächsten zwei wochen
möglicherweise noch passieren könnte
erschreckend ja auch der angriff auf die
berichte
er ist innen und ihre ausrüstung was
bedeutet das für ihre arbeit
ja das macht die arbeit nicht leichter
wir haben ja gestern dagestanden als die
demonstranten von der westseite des
kapitols vertrieben wurden von der
polizei mit tränengas und blendgranaten
die waren natürlich aufgepeitscht und
sie haben sich dann gleich auf unseren
bereich gestürzt wir hörten die worte
feinde des volkes das ist auch direkt
auf den amerikanischen präsidenten
zurückzuführen denn er hat immer und
immer wieder bei
wahlkampfveranstaltungen journalisten
unabhängige berichterstatter als feinde
des volkes bezeichnet insofern kein
wunder es macht die arbeit natürlich für
journalisten in den usa viel schwerer
kann man sich vorstellen vielen dank kt
wissen weltweit sorgen die bilder vom
sturm des kapitols für empörung der
britische premierminister johnson sprach
von schändlichen szenen im us-kongress
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen betonte sie glaube an die
stärke der us institutionen und der
demokratie und bundespräsident
steinmeier sagte diese szenen sein
ergebnis von lügen und noch mehr lügen
spalte rey und demokratie verachtung von
hass und hetze auch von allerhöchster
stelle über die reaktionen in
deutschland lars montag die
amerikanische botschaft und der
bundestag liegen in sichtweite
zueinander
doch noch nie haben die höchsten
deutschen staatsvertreter so großem
abstand genommen zu einem amtierenden
us-präsidenten in berlin herrscht
entsetzen ich bedauere sehr dass
präsident trump seine niederlage seit
november nicht eingestanden hat und auch
gestern wieder nicht
zweifel am wahlausgang wurden geschürt
und das hat die atmosphäre dafür
bereitet dass die ereignisse der nacht
erst möglich gemacht hat auch der
bundespräsident sieht die verantwortung
bei trump und zieht parallelen zum
versuch von rechtsextremen und corona
leutnant im sommer das reichstagsgebäude
zu stürmen
deshalb wende ich diese botschaft heute
auch an uns alle hass und hetze
gefährden die demokratie lügen gefährdet
die demokratie gewalt gefährdet die
demokratie
die afg die mit abgeordneten an der
berliner demonstration teilgenommen
hatte
nicht aber beim reichstag dabei war will
den vergleich nicht akzeptieren und
verurteilt die ereignisse in washington
der angriff auf das kapital das war ein
anschlag auf den rechtsstaat und der
rechtsstaat und die demokratische
institutionen sind unantastbar
deswegen ist das was dort gesamten ziert
ist auf das schärfste fordern wie aber
soll es weitergehen mit dem deutsch
amerikanischen verhältnis die spd drängt
darauf sich mehr von den usa abzukoppeln
von daher glaube ich sind wir gut
beraten sehr stark auf europa zu setzten
und letztlich auch eigene maßnahmen zu
entscheiden und nicht im geleitzug der
usa durch die weltgeschichte gehen und
da die union klar auf einen neustart
unter beiden sätze waren sich im
bundestagswahljahr eine grundsätzliche
auseinandersetzung über das
deutsch-amerikanische verhältnis an
der gewählte us präsident joe biden kann
ab dem 20 januar auf beide
parlamentskammern bauen
der demokrat john moss of gewannen bei
der stichwahl in georgia nämlich einen
sitz im senat ebenso wie sein
parteifreund raphael warnock
das melden us medien übereinstimmend
damit verlieren die republikaner ihre
mehrheit in der kammer
wo also stehen die usa nach all dem was
passiert ist dazu ein zdf spezial gleich
hier im anschluss und immer auf dem
letzten stand sind sie mit unserer zdf
heute app dort gibt es einen live blog
zu den ereignissen in washington
anderes thema jetzt corona der chef des
kanzleramtes helge braun warnt vor einem
deutlich längeren shutdown wenn die
bundesländer die gemeinsam getroffenen
beschlüsse nicht konsequent umsetzen
sollten
er spielt darauf an dass einige länder
die grundschulen doch schon ab mitte
januar öffnen wollen und nun der blick
auf die zahlen die sind weiterhin hoch
wegen der feiertage geht das robert koch
institut aber davon aus dass die daten
frühestens ende nächster woche wieder
belastbar sind axel horn hat laut
robert-koch-institut haben sich binnen
24 stunden 26 1391 menschen neu mit dem
corona virus angesteckt auch wieder sehr
hoch ist die zahl der menschen die an
oder mit coop 19 gestorben sind 1070 das
rkw betont dass während der feiertage
wohl weniger menschen getestet und auch
weniger daten an die ämter übermittelt
worden sind geimpft wurden mittlerweile
mehr als 400 17.000 menschen gegen das
virus das sind 0 5 prozent der
bevölkerung am meisten waren es im
verhältnis in mecklenburg vorpommern 13
5 pro 1000 einwohner in thüringen gerade
mal 2,5
noch ist der impfstoff knapp das soll
sich ändern wenn weitere zugelassen
werden
der impfstoff des tübinger unternehmens
cure back muss noch in der wichtigen
klinischen studie überprüft werden und
könnte im sommer auf dem markt sein
jetzt stellt kirberg mit dem
pharmakonzern bayer seinen neuen partner
vor
gemeinsam will man die zulassung
erreichen und die produktion des
impfstoffes vorbereiten richtig schief
gelaufen ist der impfstart in frankreich
ein fiasko sagt die opposition
und präsident marco steht gehörig unter
druck
seine regierung hatte eine million
impfungen bis ende januar versprochen in
den ersten sechs tagen aber gerade mal
500 16 geschafft denn ohne schriftliches
einverständnis vorweg und dann tage
lange bedenkzeit wurde zunächst niemand
geimpft
auch bei weiter hohen infektionszahlen
soll das jetzt anders werden christel
haas
operation impfen es sind prominente
fernseh ärzte die sich da in aller
öffentlichkeit die spritze verpassen
lassen
ein appell an alle skeptiker 60 prozent
der franzosen wollen sich nicht impfen
lassen
wir wollen zeigen dass wir vertrauen ins
impfen haben alle anderen sollten das
auch tun
die impfgegner sind allerdings im
augenblick das kleinste problem der
französischen regierung denn die die
wollen sind auch nicht glücklich
frankreich impft nicht in großem stil
sondern tröpfchenweise zu langsam zu
viel bürokratie unwürdig die kritik ist
vernichtend
der beginn war eine riesen versagen und
das kam sehr schlecht an
rosetti präsident makro soll in kleinem
kreis die wut gepackt haben berichten
die die dabei waren
die impfkampagne sei kein
familienausflug habe er gewettert das
müsse sich sofort ändern
die neue strategie heißt jetzt
beschleunigung nicht nur
altenheimbewohner sondern auch ärzte und
pfleger werden geimpft erste zentren wie
hier in poissy werden eingerichtet
wir werden 100 zentren in den städten
errichten
das ist nur der anfang nächste woche
sind es 300 und 500 in der darauf
frankreich ist von corona immer noch
stark betroffen
restaurants theater kinos den dicht es
gilt eine nächtliche ausgangssperre
sorge macht vor allem die mutierte form
des virus es gibt bereits zwei clustern
alle institutionen und einrichtungen die
jetzt schon geschlossen sind bleiben es
bis mindestens ende des monats
frankreich corona und die impfung die
regierung muss jetzt alles richtig
machen es geht um ihre glaubwürdigkeit
in deutschland ist dieses jahr ein
superwahljahr mit der bundestagswahl im
herbst
auch die csu bringt sich in stellung mit
ihrer traditionellen winterklausur der
landesgruppe also der abgeordneten im
bundestag
diesmal nicht im oberbayerischen kloster
seeon sondern in berlin
prominenter gast heute die kanzlerin
matthias feld im schatten des berliner
fernsehturms und nicht im verschneiten
bayern stellt sich die csu für das
wahljahr 20 21 auf
hat sich dafür niemand weniger als die
bundeskanzlerin als gast eingeladen
längst haben die christsozialen erkannt
dass der bruch mit merkel vor drei
jahren ein schwerer fehler war
für angela merkel eine genugtuung das
ist ein lebendiges buch geworden über
die vielen jahre mit verschiedenen
kapiteln und das kapitel dass wir seit
geraumer zeit gestalten ist ein kapitel
der gemeinsamkeit die zeichen der csu
stehen auf weiter so gerade auch weil
merkel nicht mehr kandidiert in der
migrations in der klima sogar in der
familienpolitik hat sich die csu
deutlich richtung mitte bewegt
parteichef markus söder hatte bereits
gestern eingestanden wie falsch die
letzten jahre waren
ich habe gelernt und es ist meine tiefe
überzeugung dass zwischen dem was eine
partei zunächst mal denkt und fühlt und
dem was die bevölkerung erwartet ist
nicht immer automatisch eins zu eins
identisch sein muss
söder setzt auffällig auf schwarz-grün
inspirierenden hatte er so ein projekt
landesgruppenchef dobrindt hat bewusst
einen anderen akzent
also selbst wenn man jetzt romantische
gefühle bekommen würde wenn sich die
grünen sehr darum bemühen würden dann
würde man sich ja nicht leichtfertig in
der unglückliche liebe stürzen dazu was
nach zwist klingt ist eine bewusste
aufgabenteilung der eine umgarnt die
grünen der andere wird sie bekämpfen
anderes thema das umstrittene pipeline
projekt nord stream 2 steht kurz vor
fertigstellung auf der kippe nun soll
eine stiftung den bau retten das hat der
landtag in schwerin beschlossen
so sollen sanktionen der usa gegen am
bau beteiligte firmen umgangen werden
die gasleitung wird seit 2008 zehn in
der ostsee verlegt und soll jährlich 55
milliarden kubikmeter gas von russland
nach deutschland liefern
ja und jetzt sind wir beim sport und da
gibt es noch mal zurück in die usa hat
er hat der sturm aufs kapitalia auch im
us-sport einige reaktionen ist allen
voran im basketball
die lbl die hatte ja schon gegen
rassismus zeichen gesetzt auch jetzt
wieder demonstrative ist niederknien der
sportler beim abspielen der
nationalhymne vor spielbeginn und
scharfe kritik am 4
der polizei sie zeigen zunächst eine
stille klare reaktion durch eine starke
symbolische geste schwarze wie weiße
sportler der nba reagieren bestürzt quer
durch die usa
das ist kein protest das ist eine
terroristische attacke spieler und
trainer prangern vor allem die
zurückhaltende vorgehensweise der
polizei an
was wäre passiert wenn schwarze menschen
das kapital gestürmt hätten
jay brown von den boston celtics zitiert
martin luther king unser amerika ist ein
gespaltenes land die nbl beweist sport
darf auch politisch sein
morgen abend das bundesliga-duell
gladbach gegen münchen der
tabellenführer ist zwar favorit die
borussia aber glaubt an die chance auf
einen heimsieg
mönchengladbach hat großes im visier den
tabellenführer der arbeitssieg von flix
bayern gegen mainz zuletzt hinterlässt
fragen wie stark ist der rekordmeister
wirklich und wie groß die lücken in der
defensive
wir gucken schon hin schauen natürlich
in analyse wo geben sich ergeben sich
räume die fohlen kommen mit offensiv
power und hoffen auf effektivität vor
dem tor
bayern ist gewarnt wir brauchen eine
andere einstellung von anfang an nicht
erst ab der 48 49 0 sondern von anfang
an mönchengladbach empfängt bayer nun
hofft auf augenhöhe der am ende bessere
laune hat sehen wir morgen das war es
auch schon von ihnen danken beim wetter
heißt es heute nacht aufpassen denn es
kann gefährlich glatt werden mehr dazu
gleich von katja honnefer das war es von
uns aber gleich macht das spezial hier
weiter mit der berichterstattung über
die ereignisse in den usa und um 10 das
heute journal mit marietta slomka sie
hat fragen an außenminister maß ihnen
noch einen angenehmen abend und bis
morgen um 7
[Musik]
meine damen und herren den ersten schnee
dieses winters brachte das tief ahmed
zum teil in norddeutschland wie in
quickborn in bremen oder in hannover am
wochenende wird es ruhiger denn das
hochamt weitet sich nach osten aus heute
nacht aber schneite es zum teil noch
kräftig besonders in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen oberhalb von 200 meter
machen sie sich auf gefährlich glatte
straßen gefasst in norddeutschland gibt
es noch einige schneeregenschauer und im
süden ist es zum teil klar und dann
sinken die temperaturen über schnee an
den alpen bis minus 11 grad sonst bleibt
die nacht etwas milder morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen minus drei
und plus vier grad und die schneefälle
ziehen sich immer mehr richtung südosten
zurück an der ostseeküste kann es auch
noch einige schneeregenschauer geben die
sonne sehen sie morgen in
schleswig-holstein vielleicht am
oberrhein und südlich der donau aber
doch ziemlich gewiss
am samstag fällt noch etwas schnee im
erzgebirge und im winterlich geht es
weiter schönen abend noch